with apologies to a handful of people
who have already heard this I'm gonna
just very briefly give a very brief
overview of kind of where these where
I'm coming from in these lectures and
that is basically I am talking about
human rights and human responsibilities
by human responsibilities I am NOT using
what iris Marion Jung called a liability
model I'm not using a legal model to
talk about responsibility that involves
blame or causality but instead I'm
making arguing about ethical and
political responsibilities to help
address structural and justices and the
enjoyment of human rights and so as you
know I'm either a lawyer nor a
philosopher I'm an international
relations scholar I work mainly on
transnational advocacy issues I work on
international norms and human rights and
most of my research has really been
about how new new norms are constructed
and enforced through human agency and so
as I said I've been drawing on on I was
young I'm very interested in what she
calls this social connection model of
responsibility which is the idea that
everyone who's socially connected to
problems of injustice is called upon to
take responsibility to resolve the
problem and I take the social connection
model and I try I'm trying to suggest I
believe and I'm interested in my chill
and others say but I believe that that
model can be extended beyond issues that
are pure structural injustice issues
okay and so for example I think the
issue today around a free speech the
right to protest the right to speech the
responsibility to respect the speech of
others and the protests of others or at
least if not respect at least not drown
it out is probably not properly a
structural injustice issue and yet I
still believe that that iris Young's
notion of this social connection model
may be a useful way to approach
it even though it's not formally a
structural injustice and so and I as
I've said in the previous two two talks
I'm also very influenced by a hunter
rent on this which is not surprising
because I was young at the influence by
a hunter rent in her discussion
responsibilities but she disagrees with
her rent about some issues and and
agrees with about others but in what
both of them agree that the shared
responsibility for undermining injustice
can only be discharged through
collective action and this I think has
and is relevant for discussions rights
responsibilities including today so now
today I want to begin by emphasizing
actually the right to protest okay which
is not normally the place you start in
talking necessarily about free speech or
the responsibility to respect the speech
of others and I want to do that partly
because I'm a scholar of transnational
advocacy and I've always been interested
in protest I think protest is should not
be the main tool of aBSI groups and
sometimes advocacy groups use protests
too much instead of being more diverse
about their tactics but obviously
protest is one of the tactics that's
essential to to bring about change in
the world and so and as various members
of my audience pointed out over the last
two days these are perilous times for
our countries and citizens have a
serious responsibility for protecting
their democracy now some and you know we
can say that one of those
responsibilities might be at times they
need to protest some distinguished
historians including Yale scholar
Timothy Snyder have drawn the analogy
between our current situation and early
totalitarianism in Germany so in his
recent book on tyranny and I do not
necessarily agree and I told him this
when he was at the Harvard Kennedy
School I do not necessarily with his
analogies between totalitarian and
trumpism I think it's more likely
possible that Trump is more of what I
call garden-variety
narcissists with authoritarian instincts
and in other words he is more common to
some of the authoritarian leaders in
Latin America that I talked about
yesterday okay but even so I agree with
Snyder's 20 lessons from the 20th
century because virtually all of those
lessons are lessons that could be
equally well applied to more
garden-variety narcissists with
authoritarian inclinations and so I
think that I would add some lessons
however and one of the lessons I would
you know he talked about defending our
institutions but I added yesterday the
lesson of the importance of continuing
to believe in and practice democracy as
the only solution to our situation
democracy got us into this and only more
democracy can get us out of it in my
mind more democracy more speech can get
us out of it but one of niners lessons
particularly relevant here and that is
one defend and institution do not speak
he says of our institutions unless you
are making them yours on or acting on
their behalf institutions don't protect
themselves and in this discussion why
defend institutions Snyder follows in
the path again of these two theorists
who have been guiding my exploration
here hunter rent and iris young so in
lecture when I discuss the rent Eichmann
in Jerusalem and she made it clear that
personal action responsibility can be
salient even under totalitarian state
and in particular the lesson that Arendt
took of the portents of political
responsibility is that and here in the
case of Denmark she says when the Nazis
met determined public opposition they
back down and she continues quote it is
the only case we know of in which the
Nazis met with open resistance and the
result seems to have been that those
exposed to it changed their minds they
had met resistance based on principle
and their toughness had melted it turns
out she says that quote the idea of
toughness itself was nothing more than a
myth of self-deception concealing a
ruthless desire for conform
at any price now can we take so young
discussing elaborating around says that
political responsibly consists of and
here quote in watching institutions
monitoring their effects to make sure
that they are not grossly harmed in
maintaining organized public spaces
worth such watching and monitoring can
occur and citizens can speak publicly
and support one another so this is
indeed what we need to be doing now we
need to be watching our institutions
monitoring them and and this is
essential for constructing a public
sphere
for setting up a dialogue and action
among citizens not only to defend their
rights but also to perform their duties
now so but I said I wanted to begin by
talking about protests and I want to and
I've tried to tell some stories just to
kind of break this up and I had a story
that was going to be a video for you
someone had to tell you about the video
instead and this is the story of the
American Political Science Association
our annual meeting which is always over
Labor Day and this year I went and
engaged in a protest at a PSA which is
not something we normally do and and I
did it accidentally I went and I got I
got there and I discovered having
breakfast with my graduate students that
some of my colleagues had were already
much wronged the ball and had discovered
that John you was going to present at
two different workshops at a PSA so John
you I think most you may know that some
of you don't John you was the lawyer who
worked in the office of the legal
counsel in the Justice Department during
the Bush administration and who wrote a
number of the so-called torture memos
okay now those these are the memos
through which the bush of and the
highest levels of the Bush
administration authorized legalized and
defined the policy
of that would become torture and
rendition by the Bush administration so
in this case we you know we in fact
weren't protesting use speech right we
wanted to protest the way that he had
written memos for the highest of the US
government the the office of the council
is the part of your government that
tells citizens what our laws mean okay
and so if there were memos that
justified action indeed that instigated
and permitted action that led to torture
and some tortured led to death and so
actually and I don't use the word war
criminal casually but I believe that at
least a court of law should explore
whether or not John you as a war
criminal and so when I discovered that
he'd been invited to speak not just at
one panel at two panels at the American
public sign Association by a very
conservative group from the the
theorists here we'll know more about him
the this gaussians I guess at Claremont
College is that right Claremont
Institute Claremont College and so was
that same group organized two events you
was there and so my colleagues that
organized a absolutely silent protest
and I thought this is what we need
because I know at a PSA that we are not
going to interrupt speech it's gonna be
really important if we're gonna protest
figure out how to do without
interrupting speech so and so I signed
on and got to the second protest not to
the first and not only that people ill I
walk to the door and someone handed me a
sign so they were very well organized
and and so the plan was this that there
was a panel we were gonna list sit down
listen the whole panel and only when you
stood up and walk to the podium we were
gonna stand up turn our backs hold our
signs out that said stamp out torture
aren't brighter and sign stands of
torture and we were gonna stay standing
quiet during the whole his whole talk
which wasn't that long and we did that
as soon as we stood up everyone
complained because that we were hoping
it was one of those rooms with
you know that we could actually be in
the back of the room but it's one of
those rooms with round tables I'm saying
that's good political sciences and room
you know kind of a ballroom II thing
with round tables and so people were
sitting around tables and everybody was
stood up and we black somebody and they
complained that we were blocking their
vision but people kind of didn't move
and and you kind of JA lead it away he
actually used tension you use humor to
defuse the tension in the room and he
said hey I'm from Berkeley people
protest me all the time I'm totally used
to this and that was good he got to
start his remarks and he goes and anyway
I can use this as evidence for a
concealed carry permit because because
in order to get a concealed carry gun
permit you need to have evidence of a
threat and so he was gonna use us he
joked as evidence of the threat he faced
at a PSA so you get his concealed gun
permit so we'd have it the next time you
come is to speak at a PSA so no this is
protected speech okay so you hear word
into the First Amendment right that in
the First Amendment even you know that
would never count for inciting violence
okay
and not only doubt they probably say
this you know he's making a joke you
know get over it and so it's it's
protected speech err on the First
Amendment it may not be appropriate a
PSA normative behavior and but but it's
like I want to give a few more details
here so at one point some local
organizers that we're not in the room we
could only enter with our badges right
some local organizers God in the room
and started shouting you know fire John
you he's a war criminal and everyone in
the room stayed very disciplined and
just held their signs we did not join in
the the chanting right because we decide
it was important to stay quiet so when
the question answer period came someone
came around said we're gonna stay
standing and I had been listening cuz of
course the good news about being quiet
and fan is you have to listen to the
whole thing I listen to the most
conservative panel on executive power in
the US government the importance of
executive power in the US government and
so so I had been framed in my
the question that I wanted to ask the
tenants of I'm never going to answer but
never going to answer my question but at
least I'll try I'll try to ask a
question on topic that will let me raise
torture and so you know so I put down my
sign but everyone else will stand it up
I moved over down the table and I threw
my hand up and I thought and for
whatever reason the guy calling it
didn't see me move and so he do that
there's the person who's right he called
on me first it was an utterly unique
opportunity which you would never get
and I tried to frame my question about
okay the problem with executive power is
what do you do if the executive course
goes over out-of-bounds and engages in
criminal behavior and the executive has
to hold you know him or herself
accountable but they won't do it of
course so what what are we doing so the
they blew me off because I had that
there was a lawyer answer the question I
had I have not used a precise legal term
at one point and so he just didn't
answer me but I felt I felt that that
was right that I had asked a question
about the substance of the panel I
didn't want to just protest and then so
afterwards I walked up and I continued
my conversation not with John you but
with the person who had blown off my
question say well let me let me try to
frame this a different way for you and
and that is how you know how can you
we've got that we've got time hope you
bear with me he this very speaker had
just joked about the administrative
state that the administrative state
could not hold itself accountable that
if he quoted someone saying it was jury
judge and everything else all right and
I said in this matter the point you just
made about the administrative state is
what's happening with executives right
they will not allow accountability to go
ahead and so we have people who we
believe may have committed crimes under
the the US war crimes Act which is the
act that that enacts the Geneva
Conventions when the UN states ratified
Geneva Conventions we enacted the Jena
conventions into federal statute it's
called the War Crimes Act by the way I
did add this
my question my public question talked
about the War Crimes Act it said it was
promoted by a Senate it was started by
Senator Republican senator from North
Carolina and it was supported by a
unanimous vote in the Senate okay and it
carries up to life imprisonment or the
death penalty and the death penalty
should there be death should should the
war crime have cause death and so we
actually point here with under US
federal statute we actually have a
practice torture that in some cases led
to death for which one could make an
argument that John you bore some
responsibility in the liability sense
right it's possible legal responsibility
for that
and could be prosecuted on the war
crimes act so and and so at that point I
explained it again he said oh I see what
you mean that's interesting so we
actually managed to have us a civil
conversation about a you know about the
topic of the panel as it related to our
protest I said people here you know some
of us have done research on this I said
I'm I just finished a paper that is
going to be published in perspective on
politics that studies quantitatively the
impact that the US torture policy had on
torture in the world and I discovered
interesting things
there's no indication that that US
policy led to more torture in the world
okay but the 40 countries that
participated actively with the United
States in the rendition detention
interrogation program those 40 countries
had worsening Human Rights practices and
that began after their collaboration
United States and have stayed present
even though that program was dismantled
so at least in 40 countries of the world
we can say their their practices the
core human rights got worse it would
appear that it might be related to their
collaboration in the United States and
and then it didn't improve it didn't
improve when that policy was dismantled
so I said this is this is like a
research talk
for some of us and we believe that this
is a serious time now III tell you all
of this just because one I want to say I
think sometimes I think people have to
protest and and it's a different issues
for different people right therefore
most of us would have there's something
that maybe each person in this room
would protest about it might be
different and there's histories here
about why because we know something
about it in my case you heard me say
yesterday I lived and I got interested
human rights because I lived in Uruguay
as a young woman and Uruguay was a
torture chamber of the Americas of the
time and many I knew people who'd been
tournament my friends were people have
been tortured okay my husband for 20
years ran the Center for victims of
torture in Minneapolis which is the
largest treatment center for torture
victims in the United States and we
learned about how difficult it is to
help torture conceal even though it's
possible okay so this is just an issue
that I take very deeply but I'm not
saying it's you know each of us has a
different maybe a different issue we we
would we would protest but that right to
protest is incredibly important and at
the same time we have to be I think
principled and very strategic about how
we use our right to protest okay
and so because as you all know you know
this both because we have ethical
responsibilities the principle because
after all responsibilities to not to
listen to not disrupt speech of others
even if I myself was not going to be
persuaded by anything John you said my
promise I would not be persuaded even
though he actually called for the
impeachment of Trump by the way I was
not very persuaded by John you anything
you would have said about torture but
other people in the room needed to
listen and it was it was essential in
that setting for me not to block the and
so that takes this issue of what are the
kinds of norms that we need and in
particularly where the current the norms
we need in different settings right in
different settings and I think one of
the issues we haven't properly explore
anything by the campus are all the
different settings
we have so what's appropriate in a in a
protest on the street which is there yes
you shout you chant you try to you know
chant louder than the other people
chanting but you know you don't engage
in violence and you don't destroy
property right and and I say that I bet
epically but also again pragmatically
you don't you pregnant you don't because
the purpose of a protest as any
organizer knows is you're trying to not
just you know convince your small group
that's already convinced you're trying
to convince a broader group and whenever
you engage in violence and destruction
of property you and immediately are in a
and you're alienating exactly the kind
of people that are the next group that
you need to persuade right and so
talking about violence on campus you
know you know that you know the
Middlebury story about Charles Murray
you know you know it was yeah the
professor Allison Sanger professor
Allison Stanger political science
professor at Middlebury she was asked by
the Republican group that invited
charles murray she did not support
murray she didn't believe in him she but
she agreed to she agreed to moderate the
panel because she thought that she
should respond to a student group that
asked her that and and then as you know
there there
he was shouted down there was a scuffle
when they walked out and she was knocked
to the ground had a concussion was
injured now Allison Stanger wrote a very
powerful memo about that experience
okay and my feeling is if you're an
organizer the last thing you want to do
is lose the Allison stingers for your
movement right and you don't want her
instead for her to be out writing a memo
that's actually discrediting your
protest okay you need to keep the
Allison stingers with you in in your
protest and so the selection of tactics
is important again for ethical reasons
important for strategic and practical
reasons but so we know what's proper I
mean we know what what you can do in the
street but then we're going to move
we've got three other we've got a couple
of other arenas we can
talk about right though I want to say
what about the public forum what about
the places where we invite where we want
to say we here we universities we invite
speakers all right what are the rules
that govern the public forum and then
what are the rules that are going to
govern other places like our classrooms
and I think in the public forum the a
protest this is sort of what I you know
what I was you know I think protest is
possible but it needs to be protested
doesn't doesn't drawn to a speech and
again we had this at the Kennedy School
just last week Betsy DeVos visited she
was talking about school choice and it
was the first a trump administration
cabinet official who had come to the
Harvard the forum is that unfilled
you've been there the heart of the
Kennedy School let's play all you know
public officials always visit there it's
very common and students are always
permitted to ask questions and we never
a script the questions we never we give
we give private places students as those
other members of the audience but we
never censor or even ask to see their
questions ahead of time right and so
they decide the ground rules would be
that people wouldn't would you know
we're gone you know the microphones were
up there's going plenty time for
questions and comments
there was not going to be a there was
not going to they were not going to
permit anyone to shout anyone down are
con Fung who's my associate dean and
who's a political theorist and someone
who worked on delivers democracy I
thought very much about this issue and
and he I want to I actually want to read
what I had it for you on a slide but I I
can't show you this slide so I wanted to
read what he said kind of long but he
said in this time of deep division what
we need most is to listen and to
understand one another instead of
circling the wagons into our separate
echo chambers the Kennedy School is all
about understanding difference in
building bridges but creating inclusive
space is especially difficult these days
because many people from all sides
rather shut the other down rather than
hear what they're saying shutting people
down is contrary to the values of this
space and of the Harvard Kennedy School
here we encourage the exchange of ideas
and different viewpoints even if we do
not agree it's important to hear and
allow other than attendance to listen
and speak as well the practice our forum
event enacts these principles by giving
speakers an opportunity to articulate
their views and then insisting they take
questions from you our audience people
the audience will as they always do here
have an opportunity to ask questions in
the last portion of tonight's events I
will ask the Harvard University Police
to escort from the forum anyone who
insists on preventing others from
speaking or hearing by disrupting this
event this is because our practice of
dialogue and debate is critical when you
prevent others from speaking or hearing
disagreeable views or when you yourself
refuse to be challenged by those who
disagree it means you are so sure that
you are right and they are wrong that
you have nothing to learn from them and
then he says but on an issue like school
choice how can anyone be so sure of
themselves so if it's I think it's quite
quite an interesting thing but also I
noticed the end he's decided to say that
at least on this issue of school choice
there are there are lots of
disagreements by lots of groups and how
can we be so sure about this he leaves
open the possibility there might be
other issues on which we would be so
sure of ourselves that we might not want
to listen in quite the same way I don't
know I haven't asked him about that but
I think that's one interpretation of
what he wrote so so so I'm able Eve that
those are appropriate rules for a place
like the forum okay but then we'd have
to step backward and we have to say okay
but what about our classrooms right and
what we know about our classrooms is
that you know as a Supreme Court version
of free speech is not going to work in
the class in our classrooms right and
it's not going to work because we are
trying to create an inclusive learning
environment where people
where people are are going to be able to
learn together right and and think
activity that's permitted by the Supreme
Court including hate speech is going to
destroy that classroom environment that
we need and so we have to think of the
we have to think that the university has
multiple purposes and one of those
purposes is the free state exchange of
ideas and that's important but it's not
the only one another purpose is
excellence in research and excellence in
teaching okay and excellence and
research and teaching may not the
Supreme Court version of of free speech
is is not necessarily going to help us
advance excellence in teaching certainly
and maybe not even excellence in
research so we need other norms they're
going to govern our classrooms and not
just the Supreme Court norms and so I
don't know some some of what I've read
on this debate suggests that we just
have to know what Supreme Court said and
that's sufficient and we know what to do
on campus and I think that's just
profoundly misleading and and if you
think twice about it anyone who's been
in a classroom things twice oh they know
that's wrong and again I I want to cite
something else that our Khan said
actually something he's he's writing is
not yet been published but because he
knows I'm working on this we've been
sending stuff to each other and he said
it's got to be wrong he goes think about
this I'm in a classroom and I call
someone you know one of my students you
know you know hey redneck or if my
student calls me professor Cinque and
some of you know him he's of Asian
origin right he goes obviously both of
those are completely unacceptable
they're permitted by the Supreme Court
but their complete length up in a
classroom and if that happened but if so
if you know we would appropriately be
called in to the dean's office and told
that that we had to have better norms
for how to run discussion and classroom
okay so we we know which is instinct
that the Supreme Court isn't going to
give us the rules we need to work in our
classrooms right that doesn't mean we
don't have norms I think it's important
that we do have norms this just has to
be a different set of norms that help us
cope with our idea of having this
inclusive learning community and and the
idea of creating inclusive learning
opportunity community goes beyond the
classroom it's really what we want for
our campus right is to have an inclusive
learning opportunity so we have to know
it's not just in the classroom it's also
what what happens in the hallways what
happens in the dormitories etc so we
face this really hard problem of how to
a balance right these different how to
handle the response the the
responsibility for respecting speech in
these different settings and what I know
what I want to say because I've talked
I've talked alessia's about sometimes
people been no responsibility view and I
actually think in this debate on campus
there's it's not about a no
responsibility of you it's about kind of
what kind of responsibilities do we have
and so some people you know feel very
deeply what I started with here and that
is that we have a responsibility
resistance right and to defend our
institutions to resistance and I believe
as I said I believe there's
responsibility to protest but at the
University I believe that responsibly to
protest needs to always be sensitive to
permitting voices of others and never
drowning out voices but but so some
people believe that their responsibility
is to protect our institutions and to
resist against the possible destruction
of our institutions but others and when
I when I um you know when I I've read
that there's a poll right there's a poll
that I talked a little bit yesterday
August 2017 national survey 101 thousand
five and current undergraduate students
shows that many college students think
forty four percent think that the First
Amendment does not protect
hate speech okay compared to 39% to
think the First Amendment does protect
hate speech and 16% who don't know but
51% and even larger group of students
agree it's acceptable for student groups
to disrupt a speaker make an offensive
or hurtful statements by loudly and
repeatedly shouting so the audience
can't hear the but in particular
52% students prefer a learning
environment quote that creates a
positive learning environment for all
students by prohibiting certain speech
or expression viewpoints that are
offensive or biased against certain
groups of people okay instead of one
where students are exposed to all types
of speech and viewpoints even if it
means allowing speech that's offensive
or biased against certain groups of
people and what what I think part is
going on is that these undergraduates
feel a deep sense of responsibility
partly in resistance but partly
responsibility to protect vulnerable
groups from speech that's hurtful
offensive or biased so we're not talking
about no responsibility here we're
talking on PA feeling responsibility to
their fellow students or feel
responsibility to vulnerable groups and
so it's a complicated issue right of how
we're going to deal with this sense of
responsibility it's I think this deep
sense of responsibility on the part of
on various sides of this this debate
okay so so I mean first you know we need
to clarify to our students and others
that in fact you do not have a right in
this country not to be confronted you
don't have a right you don't have a
legal right under the US Constitution
not to be confronted with hurtful speech
okay as interpreted by the US Supreme
Court the protections of free speech in
the First Amendment are very broad there
are only a handful exceptions to
protection offers including speech that
is quote directed to inciting or
producing imminent lawful lawless excuse
me imminent lawless action and is likely
to incite or produce a faction okay so
true threats and obscenity
so those are the that's those are the
limits on speech and they're very narrow
now the in the past many college
students liked this protection of free
speech and they liked it because they
believed in the past I mean in the old
days when some of us were young they
believed that it protected their
protests as their protest against the
Vietnam War for example and so and it
did you know it protected protests
including burning flags right and
there's a famous Supreme Court case that
says yes burning a flag is speech and it
is protected and you can burn a flag no
you can't you couldn't burn your draft
card and there's a but you could burn a
flag darker because it was but it was
action not just speech right
but even so so a previous generation of
college students liked free speech
because free speech protected their
right to protest and on issues like
burning a flag that the government could
and would come down very hard on them
but I think this generation this is why
I'm very interested in talking to some
of the students in the room and I do see
I know there are some students and rooms
some people I've known from from dinner
last night about you know how you see
this because I think this generation of
students sees the Supreme Court
protections as being really you know in
completely insufficient okay and you
know there aren't come you know German
there are kind of course Germany Poland
many other kinds in Europe that do have
prohibitions of hate speech just before
this class my I was I was skyping into
my class of the Harvard Kennedy School
and my students oddly were having their
livers it was a student presentation on
white supremacy and they were talking
about how to confront white supremacy
and they were talking about the
importance of avoiding hate speech and
one of the students in the room was
Polish and she said in Poland we have a
hate speech law and it's modeled after
Germany and she said I just think you
guys should think twice about whether
it's always best to to prohibit hate
speech so because in Poland
it's had the effect that we just can't
talk about some things right we can't
talk about some things and she wasn't
persuaded she had the feeling perhaps
that this hate speech though I had kind
of suppressed discussion to suppress
kind of the working through almost the
necessary working through that a society
needs to do in order to come to grips
with its past and plan for its future
now the so the university need not
indeed should not be governed simply by
an we need to know what the First
Amendment what our rights are and the
First Amendment but the university need
not and should not be governed simply by
narrow First Amendment interpretations
but also by broader understandings that
the first amount with regard to academic
freedom okay so this the they're all
there is also law that protects the
academic freedom the Supreme Court's had
a number of cases where they've looked
at appearance and what they said is that
universities actually the government
should not be intervening in
universities to regulate speech in
universities and and another colleague
wrote she goes this is irony now we have
the situation where the federal
government and state governments are
trying to intervene in universities
supposedly to protect free speech right
there's an irony there but the so the
issue is that other laws and other norms
need to apply and some of those laws
like academic freedom are laws that may
have constitutional protection the what
complicates this most is the fact that
there's now political manipulation
obviously of the free speech issue and
again I had a slide is going to show you
that I I'm gonna have to find the digs
I'm gonna have to read it to your fund
exact language here very sorry
[Applause]
okay and so I'm afraid my papers got a
lot of order okay well it was a
colleague just arrived back from North
Carolina and she was talking about
what's going on in North Carolina
universities and her point was that now
nowadays because there's so much
political manipulation of free speech
issue that North Carolina universities
that the students arrived and they were
greeted by white supremacist banners
that were hanging from the you know
hanging from doorways that were seen as
free speech that people that's that
groups were writing build a wall on the
they were writing build a wall on the in
chalk on the on the sidewalks and that
when a student went to rub that off that
Stern was disciplined the student who
went to rub off build a wall with
discipline not the not anyone else okay
that legislators are there's a whole
series of laws being written by
legislators around this country that are
trying to mandate what universities can
and cannot do around this free speech
issue and so there's actually a lot of
danger here and because of the political
manipulation of free speech okay so I
want to just suggest that exactly in
this moment where there's political
manipulations where it's so fraught it's
all the more incumbent on us on
academics faculty students staff in
universities to think through policies
that are nuanced in terms of a context
you know where the free speech occurs
right that take into account the
multiple that take into account the
multiple
have and responsibilities of
universities so we recognize it's not
just that not only the free promotional
ideas but these other issues of
excellence in teaching and research
right as well as the creation of
inclusive learning communities so we
have to work hard I think and think
carefully to work on these policies and
at the same time I think people all of
us have to be very strategic because
exactly because there's political
manipulation going on we don't have I
that's the right word we have it's it's
very important to be thoughtful
extremely thoughtful about the choice of
tactics ok now this this comes back you
know I teach social movements ok any
good social moment organizer knows that
you choose your tactics carefully
because you have to you know we have
some we use sometimes teaching
organizing called the spectrum to allies
mic spectrum allies is here I have my
supporters here I hope you know it's
like a what's it like it's like a
rainbow or something here are my
supporters here and over here are my
absolute opponents and in between are
the passive my passive supporters and
there's my opponents passive supporters
and then there's a big group in the
middle that are just the undecided okay
so on this issue you know people who
care deeply about about what's at stake
need to figure out how to not just unify
your own supporters how you're going to
get your passive supporters on board how
are you going to get the undecided onto
your side and and maybe how could you
even drive the passive supporters away
from your opponents okay
so in this case if we believe that very
hateful speech is one of the things that
were opposed to how do you get people on
your side and I want to say first
violent tactics truly will not do it
it's a huge mistake and anyone who's you
know I mean I
know who the anti-shah are someone made
you know us I'm going to tell me but the
this has been a very pernicious
influence on on on the the our ability
to gain support from these passive
supporters or from the undecided okay so
the destruction of property and violence
is just I think the the wrong tactic
this the but in addition to that I mean
in addition to you know it's more it's
really more than just violence it's
really choosing tactics that attract
people and I had a slide that slide I
most regret not having is I had a slide
that comes from a person I work with who
teaches actually social mona organizing
and it's a slide about laughter vism as
a tactic and he has three photos of
different groups that are using humor to
support their cause and so there's one
clowns and finland this bride power a
group of bride power people or who are
responding in charlottesville somehow
they all went out and got got wedding
dresses at secondhand stores and dressed
up as brides but the most telling one
and this is what i want to end with
today is one what a kind of an anti-nazi
group in germany did okay and they they
were confronting a march of some kind of
white supremacist group i don't think
there were Nazi group cuz I think a Nazi
group wouldn't be permitted to march but
there was some kind of supremacist group
and they were marching and so the anti
supremacists decided that they would go
out and get fundraising they would
fundraise for themselves they would use
the march of the of the supremacist as a
way to fundraise for the amp is for
emphasis group and they would do that by
getting commitments from all of the
local merchants but also their their
friends and families to pay so much
money for every meter that the Nazis
marched for the supremacists marched
okay and then they went and they drew
they painted on the on the floor exactly
how much money they had earned they were
going to earn
by the time the white supremacist group
got to this place right and so as the
people were marching they had to look
down and say I've now helped them earn
and there was the photos can show you
was 2500 euros at this point of the
March I've now helped the group that
opposes me the anti-nazi group earned
two thousand five hundred yards and I
just thought was it brilliant that's
what that's what we need by tactics it's
so clever it earns money and can you
imagine what's going on in the head of
some of some supremacist group as they
march knowing that they're earning money
for their opponents and so what what
this whole Free Speech Movement needs
it's we have responsibilities those
promises or ethical ones but we also
here have responsibilities that are
political ones in a good sense of
political and that's we're trying to
fashion our world and there's a
political struggle going on here and if
we aren't really smart how we handle
this issue we're not going to be able to
gather the widespread support we need to
to further our concern with human rights
thank you I really would like comments
and I'd really like people to share with
me things that have that art are
happening here at Yale okay of what's
going on the university structures its
own classes and exchange our views and
the teacher the professor is the
moderator and can say mister you're out
of line just keep mm-hmm
no I mean when so I'm you know when I
teach my class I oh we have the
beginning I always say all points of
view are welcome in this class all
points of view are welcome and and it's
it's going to be important you know it's
important me apart but they need to be
stated in a way that is civil and
ideally persuasive the whole point is
we're trying to you know persuade one
another you have to make good arguments
in favor of your ideas okay it's not
just speech for speeches sake we're in
an academic class and then I actually
asked my dear Shukur so if you'll think
about this I actually said and when I
say that we're gonna welcome all points
of view I'm I you know in the you can
everyone can respond and disagree in a
firmness possible manner right you can
disagree affirm sauce no matter but in a
civil manner that you met that backs up
your point of view with good arguments
and then I say maybe this goes to par
let's say and you know the nonverbal to
you know we see the nonverbal we see
when you're rolling your eyes you know
and I really don't think that rolling
your eyes is the way to have a
discussion in the classroom you don't
like if someone says no you know if
someone says you argue with them you
discuss with them don't sit there and
roll your eyes you know so that's what I
do yeah someone posted that forum the
discussion in the comments preceding we
also had on the web sheet Rome put the
party on campus that was also a big
controversy that they were posted to
that page then people discussed it and
it seems like the typical outlets of
campus talk and forum and discussion
aren't play here it's Facebook something
is really meant for that and something
that does only have the intention of
becoming that charms and they're
becoming that way and it becomes thing
that people talk about on campus is that
professors and class like the typical
University structure doesn't really have
an effect I can't really play so I guess
my question is where can anyone step
into that because as a student I don't
feel that these typical campus forums
are really where this type of discussion
is happening okay cuz you say it's all
happening on Facebook I think that
specifically but yeah I know those two
inches in particular happen in the past
yeah that was something but do you think
that it you know is it because there
aren't places on campus people aren't
organizing events on campus where you
can talk about it or you don't like
those events
wipsy I didn't missus yell language
right yeah so the Yale political okay
daily at least with that the
conversation was all online and the
comments that received the most I guess
visibility were those that were kind of
trafficked by the massive okay this view
is the one I want to get the most likes
to and then when you look at the post
that was the one that was up front and
it went from something that should have
been a dialogue it became more response
right now I completely agree with you
that to have this discussion it needs to
be you know it needs to be in some kind
of forum where people can want to
articulate their arguments and you know
in more depth than you can in a Twitter
post or a Facebook that the responses
are not you know like or dislike which
is you know but really you know what why
do you like it
how do you just like it and then the
person who dislikes it articulates
position so I completely agree that
social media is really not set up to
have the kinds of discussions we need to
have but then you know where if where
are they happening there's then who is
organizing those discussions
launcher problem that whatever
university does can't really impact that
and I see that I just can't see but it
but if you're you know I know dorm or
where you know if institutions that you
do you know spend time with and when you
do gather together with your fellow
students if they held events would you
attend so is there anything that would
get you to I mean but not you you always
said you would be there would get your
friends what would get your friends to
an event where you could have a deeper
discussion food I mean no food is always
a good no food is always important no
and so no i yeah anyways to provide food
and and organize the discussion but
close to home you're not not some of you
have to go far away for you know but no
i'm close to home quote in your dorms in
your clubs whatever i don't know where
people need it yet but you know we were
actually thinking before for these
castle lectures maybe one of these
lectures should be a more people come
could we get more of a dialogue that way
I think
the other thing that talking about
people will say they're interested in
don't show up say okay so that doesn't I
think it would get more students about
justice it but I think it was either
kinds of student whether likely don't
want to talk about these things rather
than those yeah yeah okay the question
of why do protest and I think correct me
if I'm wrong the arguments people
process to push push we the undecided
population but my question my cynicism
comes from the idea that the undecided
attack doesn't exist and you know the
undecided people who choose to say that
they're undecided
are in fact making a decision you know
like I believe a political is you know
like a decision to not engage not a
decision to not have a decision like so
like I'm curious as to what you think
like why do you think like we need to
promise to persuade people when in fact
I think like process of the week to make
a statement about what you're so one I I
do I did say that I thought there was
some identity purpose in protest I do
think you know why do i protest
torturous I think it was who I am and
what I what I've worked on but but
protests in my mind and this is someone
you know I worked on social movements
must be so much more than simply a
statement of our identity so what you
know so what did I want to do with John
you so did I I didn't think I was gonna
persuade John you at all I actually
wanted to convince the people who
invited him not to invite him again well
well no but I think what this what I'm
thinking I'm thinking we just created
enough of a stink we disrupted their
panel they they're probably a little mad
because no one was paying attention to
what they were saying right you know cuz
the academics are very vain we want to
hear what what we want people isn't us
and we were totally distracting the
audience from what
four of the five panelists were saying
right and so we just want to say next
year think twice before you invite John
you he's trouble he's trouble and then
we want the APSA to think next year
think twice before you approve a panel
with John you on it now I've got people
who know more about a PSA than I do but
but that the idea that was was to
persuade not not to turn them into you
know you know people who care about
human rights but just to say you know
John root John you it's just not the
kind of person who you would want on
acne panel all over the world I've seen
it all of the Romo so the person I got
this from with were they this the
Serbian activists in outpour in Serbia
who we're the people help get rid of
Milosevic okay and they described very
capable you know Serbia was not like a
friendly place for anti Milosevic
organizers okay
the Serbs were they embrace the lowest
vision they agreed with some of his you
know genocidal and racist beliefs but oh
poor and other people turned it around
and brought in people who were indeed
you know I'll call them undecided in
other words they were indeed willing to
shift their allegiance away from
Milosevic when he became too
controversial and too costly to them and
that has happened it so these per
activists now have a training thing they
go all over the world and I can give you
I mean I can give you all many many many
examples where that happens it doesn't
turn true human rights it doesn't turn
undecided people all into true human
rights activists but it withdraws their
support it removes the pillars of
support from these authoritarian
governments and that's what you need you
remove power support they fall
okay and they fall not just because you
know 60% of the people are are committed
you know people who believe in human
rights point do you have do you see this
is the degree to which we have to
protest to have undecided movement is
the question of sort of you know having
just assumed you are on the other side
using violence do you keep using
non-violence like up to what point yeah
change your method right so I mean you
know so when I when I've used lots of
videos for for you know going back to
Gandhi looking at Martin Luther King
look at the training that that they did
the training they did and that was we
are going to face violence yeah and when
we face violence we need to use the
opponent's violence against them to be
legitimate the opponent okay and that
was the you know the amazing essence of
these nonviolent struggles is that they
by consciously choosing non bonds and by
training people to to not react to
violence they D legitimize their
opponents and they they ultimately
changed the attitudes of of you know
they're changed the attitudes of large
chunks of the population that had
previously supported their opponents you
know i-i-i use it i used to use a book
called a force more powerful to the
power of non-violent action and it's all
you know we this notion of non-violence
as being is kind of airy kind of people
who but they were so strategic they were
so well-trained and they knew what they
were about and they knew what they're
about was was forcing forcing violence
by the other side to D legitimize the
other side okay and that so it wasn't a
it wasn't a kind of
naive choice at all yeah I have a
question but before that a rather
depressing irony to the John Hughes
story I was on the absent council
meeting the day before all this happened
that never was going to happen and first
of all it's a it's something called an
affiliated group or they're absent
doesn't actually approve the panel's
okay
but worse than that there was sort of
there's a lot of hand-wringing you know
they're gonna be protests and so forth
but the allocations of panels is based
on know all that is some so we so then
we've lodged a protest it didn't occur
to us to lodge a protest to to ABS the
request that our numbers be subtracted
from the size of the panel yeah so I
will I will point I just I will write
back to the organizers to say at a
minimum if they won't respond to our
protest that at a minimum they have to
subtract our numbers from the panel guys
thank you for reminding me and I didn't
know that universities education and
obviously what goes on in classrooms is
one thing and what goes on I'll spin in
you as these other it's different I
don't have any problem with saying I
don't think all points of you're welcome
in the classroom I mean if you're
teaching a biology classes somebody
wants to talk about creation obviously I
mean all points of view on topic on
topic hard issue with speech in
universities is more these public forums
yeah where it's not in the classroom and
it's obviously there's very different
certain rules for public universities
and private universities and all that
sort of thing but but it seems to me
that there the problem is and what folks
a lot of the shouting people down and so
on is that the speakers are really
looking for something else they're
looking for a platform then what are you
looking for legitimation they're looking
for the increment or of the university
they they want you know say I gave a
talk or something yeah in another forum
and then it's the the protesters want to
deny it in that and so you know that's
the really hard question and me my own
view about that is even so but this is
personal you know I wonder what you
would say when people come and ask me
for resources to bring someone here as
an in my administrative capacity for me
the real question is is there gonna be
an active educational value at it yeah
not you know and if there is you might
have to even call out the campus police
and so on to particular thing right but
I mean so so saying if you if you if you
bring sitting politicians or people
actively seeking office first of all you
know you're basically get a stump speech
this probably not going to be much
value-added secondly they're looking for
they're looking for legitimation which
you don't have any particular reason to
or to not get and thirty-year then you
get all this stuff about well then
you've gotta have balance we've got to
have other views and so you know my
instinct is is to just put this to you
isn't isn't the real question in a
university is there going to be real
educational value attic you or not
rather than
I completely agree on that and I think
that but I think what happens is
universities need to have get their get
their act together by articulating what
their criteria are for inviting for
inviting and and because one of the
things that's happening with this
political manipulation of speech is
people are gearing up to provoke to
provoke getting uninvited okay so you
get invited and then you get uninvited
and if you get uninvited then you're
going to sue okay so the invitation
decision is very important in
universities have to get on top of it
right now because you can say these are
criteria just like we do with admitting
students right well or whatever these
are a criteria this is what we're using
to make our decision we looked at we
looked at all the possible speakers we
decided these speakers did not have
educational and we didn't invite them
but the situation of inviting people and
then disinviting them is you know I
think really what causes problems yeah
or or having fellows and uninviting
fellow says you know I could give a bad
example from the Kennedy School it's our
recent decision to make
Chelsea nanny not a fellow you know that
so you need to but but our you know some
are Dean you know Chelsea manly was
coming for you know one day to give a
talk she should just come and give a
talk
since when do we wait you know this
notion I'm going to make her not a
fellow was was poorly handled and so so
if we're going to confront these issues
where people are getting ready to sue us
for uninviting them we need to be really
careful who we invite when you get some
centralized decision and criteria for
inviting and it's going to vary because
the Kennedy School is cannot not invite
sitting public officials you know we're
a school of public policy how many
people like Betsy vos there is part of
what we're teaching students to go into
you know government as well as other
public official activities so but I
think I think Arkham I think they chose
carefully they chose enshu school choice
where they felt that me that we might be
able to have a debate on an issue of the
day
you know in not just so-so each party
University may have different rules they
have stuff with themselves you can have
your rules but a you know of the
political the Yale political unions that
was called yeah got it's got to have
different rules right but they have
their own rule they have to have figure
out their own rules and buh-buh-buh we
don't I think what we really want to
avoid are these invitations and uninvite
a shion's because of threats of violence
because that's like I think that's just
unacceptable that people are uninvited
because of violence because of threat of
violence we want people invited for
great criteria because expressed well
this is this is someone who this is like
a place of support presence not just a
place where like the adults around this
can expressly you know I I completely
agree that if that we could talk about
dormitories as yet a different setting
with a different mix of norms okay but
the crucial issues exactly where we draw
the line right where is the line that we
would call you know the kinds of hurtful
speech that will you know either when
the classroom would not lead to a
productive classroom discussion or in a
dorm would make make living together
impossible okay so you say what is it
that's hurtful speech right but then we
had
you know where do you draw the line you
say this is not hurtful but it's you
know someone should take this person
aside and talk to them and we have this
book if I bring up a discussion we had
last night is it okay if I bring up the
one about so last night we're talking
about the class where as one of the
students was presenting they kept
talking a business man business than
business man and all the women in the
class were starting to feel like enough
of this businessmen stuff and then the
issue is business men per se I would say
is not per se a hurtful speech right and
the you know so the professor could have
said you know gently you know you don't
not a kind of so said or business women
you know just to kind of give a little
nudge but and that might done the trick
they would have no of course
businesswomen I mean maybe I should say
business people and then we get on a
different track right but maybe also the
one of the fellow students could just
take this person aside said you know
when you say business man we think you
mean only men go into business and you
know you should try really talking about
business people in the future and that
might have just solved it right there
you know so I do think or here's a
question I have for you guys okay
because I am getting worried that with
the pronoun issues around transgender
people that I'm glad i'm engaged in
hurtful speech when I'm in a classroom
that's you know because I'm not using
the right proton pronoun but I tell you
that I'm having a really really hard
time in a in a good size classroom
memory of my students first names I work
really hard in the first names I don't
know if I can promise to to say the
right pronoun okay now you know is that
is you know I would prefer we not draw
the line there that my inability to
pronounce the right pronoun it's going
to be hurtful to someone okay because I
think I I can't I'm not sure if I is a
student I'm working intimately with on a
senior essay or my graduate since of
course I'll know us I'll know what they
asked me to do and I'll make an effort
to do it right but but you know what you
know where the issue exactly is where do
we draw the line and and I think we have
to be much more careful about that
because if everything becomes hurtful
then it's going to make its going to
make discussion difficult
[Music]
[Music]
so I feel like on this issue the debate
United States has gone beyond what's
happening in most countries okay but not
completely like I know in our in Latin
America recent you know it used to be in
Spanish you know the the you know if you
said company arrow that would be
everybody company arrows that would be
all of you and nowadays you must you
must say company arrow see company eros
and you know see other animals in see
llama so you have to give the both the
masculine and the feminine as and so
it's it's a one of those gestures that's
now become necessary in talking to sir
to in certain places with certain
audiences so there's a move in this
direction to be much more sensitive
around speech and but I just think that
we are still kind of light years ahead I
had in not even necessarily and I in a
ahead in Explo in grappling with these
issues not in resolving them and
personally know I think we should not
change Shakespeare to you know to to
satisfy the audience's concerns
because you British you know you know
the unanswerable question right but you
know a lot I think it a lot of us teach
historical material and in the historic
material you always get into you know
people you get into people who you know
lived in the 19th century limit and you
you constantly have to contextualize
things it's important just
contextualized say these woman you know
suffragettes for example were advanced
in some ways and thing out women's
rights and in other ways they were very
much people of their time and yes they
were racist many of them were racist ok
I think it's important to contextualize
them but not necessarily say they're for
their contributions to women's rights
struggles are suspect because of you
know we should we should dismiss all of
their contributions because it's not
your you you fail to understand people
in their period in their time but but
but I think it's important we could talk
about things without having to censor
things yeah Charlotte has been yeah
Charlotte's been like helping me for
three days
please ask me a question Charlotte
with the idea that the Academy needs to
do some serious self-reflection about
while we're fighting about Halloween
costumes other people in America are
just sick and tired of watching I might
not be a white nationalist but I'm sick
of feeling like I am a racist I'm stupid
I'm morally inferior because I don't
know
the most progressive and I know a lot of
people that are not up to speed with
Yale standard of you know all these
things that we're talking about and
they're not white nationalists they
voted for Donald Trump and I just feel
like in the midst of this discussion but
I mean somewhere there they're just
smooth to be in this moment like the
Academy we can't just sit here talking
about you know our ideal of what this
should all look like I mean that's never
gonna stop people people just continue
to vote for the Donald Trump's if we
don't somehow open up a place where
people can say yeah I don't know about
this pronoun thing you're talking about
it doesn't mean that I'm insensitive to
transgender people it's just not part of
my I think of a two-finger right yeah
yeah this is a good political science
meeting yeah right on topic this idea
sorry to put you on the spot but if at
all you're sort of over the course of
three days you're you're thinking on
vote has changed both with respect to
the population that Charlotte is talking
about which may feel belittled neglected
however you want to describe it but sort
of your time out at dinner you know well
so if I were gonna end if I has an Andy
Romar's was gonna say to people is what
I have found and this is what I I don't
think I don't expect that anyone would
be
Inessa is going to be persuaded by some
of my arguments you know and and we've
had really good debate over that but
what I'd hope is that ii think i think
the fruitfulness for discussion of
really bringing responsibilities back in
the debate over human rights that's what
i would like to leave you with it i have
found it personally
I have found it fruitful to bring
responsible ways back in it helps me
rethink certain issues I took for
granted and help it gives me a language
to use to talk about issues that that
I've been wanting to talk about and so
so I won I think it's fruitful to think
about responsibilities I have not
changed my mind on voting no why because
I mean ultimately last time I heard
Donald Trump got fewer votes then not
just that Hillary Clinton he got fewer
votes I believe than Mitt Romney right
okay so people sometimes sometimes were
blowing it out of proportion
okay by this amazing and we're actually
to actually believing it's part of the
Trump mystique that this was a huge
victory that things have dramatically
changed in this country basically the
Republican Party went and voted for the
Republican candidate there were some
interesting shifts among rural voters
I'm not denying that okay but he didn't
he did not get more votes than then then
Romney did and the prom I do think and
we talked yesterday use voting went up
right but a lot of people stayed at home
you know a lot of people stay at home
I do think that we're talking midterms a
crucial issue is you know is getting the
people to stay at home out to the polls
and that could make an immense
difference so yes you know we this is
important we have to put in a protecting
our institutions important but the most
important thing is I think is getting
you know it's getting our institutions
back to doing their job which is you
know to check and balance one another we
need a Congress that can balance an
executive we need a Supreme Court that
can balance the you know the executive
and the Congress and we can't do that
without elections no amount of
resistance if it doesn't also focus on
voting including the individuals
possible to vote is going to ultimately
give us what we need okay my question in
brief is about I guess the interplay
between free press and free speech and
how the media and Facebook and other
social media was mentioned earlier - um
how these kind of suit forces combine to
influence conversations and speech in
the country in to dictate how these
conversations are adding cycling
increasingly conversations are confined
to those spaces are at least the most
back-and-forth kinds of conversations
whereas and they happen on TV or they
happen on social media and then we
retreat to our camps um so I guess my
question is uh where's the balance when
it comes to that sphere because it is so
powerful in influencing discourse yeah
mm-hmm um well it's a great question I'm
not really sure I have a good answer for
you and I mean one of the reasons you
know the media one thing we know what
the media is it's going to focus on the
negative right it's and I've did
something I'm working on a human rights
area why do people think there's more
suffering in the world today than ever
before it's not you know it's actually
because there's a big media effect when
the media focuses on the negative right
if it believes it
but not if it's controversial is if it's
sexy it leads if it you know so in this
whole free speech debate one of these
things really important is the media is
just waiting to get another you know
Berkeley destruction of property to blow
it all out of proportion right and I
just think that people should really be
thinking about how to deny the me the
these negative examples that they're
going to use this ghost of Charlotte's
point you know they're gonna use to
publicize the all people gonna know you
know if there's a violent episode here
on yeah at Yale no you don't want people
to when they think of Yale to think
about the Halloween debate you know
there's so much going on at Yale there's
so much and just from talking to people
at dinner over the last few nights I've
just been incredibly impressed with
what's happening especially students
with the thinking that you students are
doing the Yale political union there's
so much cool stuff going on so you know
you it's really not you really don't
want people to think yelling think
Halloween right and so so part of this
is I think just trying to figure out how
to control you and this is my notion of
organizing you know I think you figure
how to how are you gonna how are you
going to control that the Nate that the
media's desire for negative news and
give them something else and give them
something that can is persuasive to
people to try to bring them over to it
to your side but I'm I'm happy I'm going
to a train but I'm not actually rushing
in the doors I'd be happy any people
have questions or you want to pursue
issues I'm happy to stick around and
talk to you
[Applause]
[Music]
you